저는 청남동 명품거리에 와
있습니다. 보시면은 지금 공사하고 있
현장들도 꽤 많이 돼요. 그쪽에는
한섬에서 그 플래그십도어 그 지금
리모델링 공사 중이고 지금 이쪽으로
보시면은 다 꽉 차 있잖아요. 그죠?
여기 뭐 코스도 있고 뭐 아르마니도
있고 그 옆에 이제 제일인드버그도
저기 그 신세계 이미 가지고
계시거든요. 근데 제가 알고 있기로는
그 제일인드버그와 관련된 회사로 알고
있어요. 그래서 지금 저기도 최근에
어 리모델링해서 사용하고 있고
그다음에 지금 저쪽 옆에 보면은 그
아크레도 신 4사옥도 지금 건축 중에
있습니다. 네. 그리고 이쪽 자측에
가면은 그 이수만 회장님이 지금
건물을 신축을 했는데 거기 마이바그가
들어옵니다. 지금 외관이 어느 정도
보이거든요. 그래서 제가 한번 직접
걸으면서 설명을 좀 드리도록
하겠습니다.
가시죠. 네. 그래서 지금 자측에
보이는게 그 이수만 회장님 건물인데
가림막을 철거했습니다. 그래서 정말
영롱한 그 건물이 완성이 됐는데 여기
이제 마이바가 들어올 예정이에요.
그래서 지금 어느 정도 공사가 좀
완료됐고 여기 건너편에는 그 아크레도
신사이 지금 신축되고 있고 원래 이제
주유소 부지였거든요. 그게 평당 한
3억 9천 정도의 매각이 됐었습니다.
여기 옆에는 그 콘스탄틴이 들어올
예정인데 조감도를 봤는데 진짜 엄청
화려하고 엄청 멋지게 리모델링을
합니다. 그리고 지금 여기 좌측에는
원래 티파니가 들어올 예정이었어요.
원래 이제 되게 큰 현수막이 있었는데
뭐 이슈 때문에 어 지금 조금 많이
딜레이됐습니다. 뭐 자세한 내용을
설명드릴 순 없지만 그다음에 지금
왼쪽 건물은 이제 샤넬이 들어와 있고
쭉가 볼게요. 네.
[음악]
그래서 저기 뒤에 보이는 저 건물도
비어 있는 건물 같이 보이잖아요.
근데 실제로 등기부 등분을 떼서
보면은 보테가로 계약이 되어
있습니다. 그래서 2023년 그니까
무려 한 2년 동안 지금 저렇게
비어놨어요. 네. 여기 기업들이
대부분 들어오기가 되게 어렵기 때문에
일단은 계약을 해 놓고 인테리어나
이런 거에 신경을 굉장히 많이
씁니다. 그래서 지금 저기 뒤에
보이는 저 건물도 일단 자리부터 잡아
놔요. 보증금이 나와 있는게 한
60억 정도로 잡혀 있습니다. 그래서
그 정도로 임대료 수준도 굉장히 좀
높을 것으로 예상이 돼요. 이쪽
부분에 있는 건물들 보셨겠지만 되게
유명한 뭐 페레가모라든지 샤넬이라든지
뭐 까르띠에라든지 되게 유명한
업체들이 많이 들어와 있고 그리고
여기 지금 반클립도 들어와 있고 저기
팬디도 들어와 있고 제가 임대료를
여기서 정확히 공개할 순 없지만 정말
엄청난 금액입니다. 그래서 대부분 다
몇억이 넘는 금액이라고 보시면 될 거
같아요. 그리고 지금 여기
로에베라든지
얘기하고 싶다. 임대 얼만지.
어, 저기 인근에 어, 일단
건물주분들한테 혼나기 때문에 임대료는
자세하게 얘기하지 않겠습니다. 그래서
정말 부르는게 갑일 정도로 그 상상
이상의 어, 그런 임차 수요들이
굉장히 좀 많다라고 보시면 될 거
같아요. 여기 그리고 외국인
관광객들도 많이 오고 있습니다.
이쪽으로 좀 더 내려가서 제가 다른
건물들도 좀 보여 드리도록
하겠습니다. 네. 저기 뒤에 보이는
저 건물이 프라다가 90년도 중간에
매입해서 아직까지 가지고 있는
건물입니다. 그래서 프라다가 명품
업체 중에 가장 먼저 여기를 매입을
했어요. 그래서 원래 이제 되게 한
2, 3층짜리 건물로 쓰다가 지금
저렇게 멸시를 한 다음에 건물을 짓고
있습니다. 지하도 굉장히 많이 파는
걸로 알고 있고 공사비가 무려
공시된 근데 그게 최소 금액이고 아마
그거보다 더 높을 것으로 예상이
됩니다. 정말 말도 안 되는 금액을
들여서 지금이 건물을 지금 짓고 있고
그리고 건축 설계하시는 건축가분이
드메롱이라고 제가 예전에 콩빌딩
설계하신 분 말씀드렸을 때 그거
설계했던 분입니다. 그래서 되게
유명한 건축가분이 어 설계를 해
가지고 지금 건물을 짓고 있는데 아마
이제 내년 한 중순 정도에 중공될
예정이에요. 이쪽으로 좀 더 보시면은
저기 건너편에 루이비통 건물이
있거든요. 그래서 루이비통이 저희가
금융이기 때 매입을 했어요. 금융
위기 때 매입을 해서 지금까지 가지고
있는데 원래 해외부동산을 투자하지
않았는데 해외부동산을 처음 투자한
사례라고 합니다. 그래서 그 정도로이
거리의 매력을 느껴서 그때 금융이기
때 아무래도 그때는 건물 시장이 되게
안 좋았거든요. 건물을 막 되게
던지는 때였고 그리고 굿찌도 그때
당시에 매입을 했어요. 그때 당시에
되게 싼 가격에 매입을 해 가지고
지금까지 보유하고 있고 어떻게 보면
이승만 회장님도 그때 당시에 매입을
했어요. IMF 딱 끝나고 나서 되게
저렴한 가격에 매입을 했는데 그런
명품 업체들이 좀 선점해 가지고 미리
매입을 해서 많은 신 차익을 남기고
있습니다. 그리고 지금 무이비통 같은
경우에는 그때 당시에 한 2만 불
정도에 매입을 했다라고 해요. 그래서
지금 환율로 보자면 약 한 28억
정도 되는데 물론 이제 그때 당시
가격으로는 굉장히 큰 금액입니다.
근데 지금 시세로 봤을 때는 최소한
1,200억 이상 그 정도 이상 될
것으로 좀 예상이 됩니다. 그리고
루이비통 같은 경우에는 뒤에 건물도
매입을 했어요. 전체에 한 500,
4억 정도 들여서 매입을 한 다음에
아마 이제 지경으로 레스토랑을
쓴다라고 합니다. 그래서 그 정도로
명품 업체들이 상당히 좀 많이 가지고
있어요. 앞에 보시면은 기사에 아마
많이 나갔는데 노렉스가 들어올
예정이에요. 지금 임대차 계약이 되어
있고 사실 이렇게 막 둘러보면 건물이
그렇게 많지 않아요. 대부분 다 명품
업체가 직접 매입을 해 가지고 쓰고
있고 임대할 만한 건물들이 많지
않습니다. 워낙 이제 장기 계약 돼
있고 임대료도 되게 높다 보니까 건물
나와 있는게 없어요. 최근에 다
팔렸습니다. 또 임대료도 부르는게
갑이고 자리가 없다 보니까 빌딩
가격도 부르는게 갑입니다. 명품
거리는 다른 상권과 비교해서는 정말
다른 분위기다라고 보시면 될 거
[음악]
같습니다. 네. 그래서 명품 매장
같은 경우에는 뭐 백화점 안에 들어갈
수도 있긴 하지만 여기 건물에 통으로
들어가서 플래그십 매장을 쓰려고 하는
수요가 되게 많거든요. 들어갈 만한
건물조차도 일단 없고 그리고 임대료는
부르는게 갑입니다. 정말 임대 시장도
좋고 건물 시장도 되게 탄탄하고
그리고 이쪽 길에 건물을 살려고 하는
사람이 되게 많아요. 명품 업체가
대부분 다 이쪽에 소유를 하고 있기
때문에 나중에 이런 기업이나 명품
업체에 매각을 할 수도 있습니다.
정말 좀 특수한 거리고 상징성 있는
거리기 때문에 저는 명품 거리는 지금
너무 좋다라고 생각을 해요. 제가
여기를 꽤 많이 분석을 했었고 여기
등기부를 제가 다 출력해서
확인했거든요. 그리고 여러분들 심지어
네이버 부동산 들어가서 여기 1층
비어 있는 거 한번 보세요. 하나도
없습니다. 단 한 게도 없어요.요
명품거리는 제가 지금이 흥분돼서
얘기하는데 정말이 600m 정도 거리
되는이 거리가 정말 상징성 있고
양극화가 되게 심하거든요. 그래서
여러분들 전 데이터도 제가 보여
드렸지만 자산가들은 계속 늘어나고
있어요. 이렇게 건물 통으로 플래그신
매장에 명품 매장 쓸 만한 건물이
여기 도로밖에 없습니다. 앞으로 저는
더 좋아질 것이라고 생각이 들어요.
지금 뭐 신년대도 있지만 여기 인근에
이제 재건축 이슈들도 있잖아요. 진짜
막 몇백억 넘는 아파트들이 많이
생겨날 거고 그걸로 인해서 이쪽으로
많이 사람들이 올 거 같거든요.
그니까 다른 나라도 비슷해요. 뭐
오모테도도 그렇고 뭐 오번가도 그렇고
뭐 런던에 있는 명품 거리도 그렇고
아무리 경기가 안 좋아도 명품 거리에
있는 상업용 빌딩은 절대 망하지
않습니다. 이건 제가 계속 보면서
느낀 거예요. 저는 명분거리를
고객분들한테 설명할 때 정말 확실하게
말씀드 여기는 진짜 망가지지 않을
거고 여러분들 명품 거리를 한번 계속
유심히 보시면 좋을 거 같고 앞으로
최고가도 계속 경신할 것 같습니다.
매매 사례를 좀 말씀드리면 여기
인근에 이제 한 4억 한 초중반
정도에 매각된 사례가 최근에 이제 두
건 정도 있어요. 임대 시세가 일단
통으로 나온 건물 자체가 없고요.
최근에 이제 기사 나왔던 로렉스 건물
같은 경우에는 연면적이 300평이 안
되는데 한 1억 5천 정도에
맞춰졌습니다. 그걸로 대비했을 때
평당 한 50만 원 정도 돼요. 근데
그것도 제가 봤을 때는 싼
금액입니다. 최소한 50만 원부터 한
100만 원 뭐 그 이상까지도 될 거
같아요. 앞으로. 그리고 여러분들
5번과의 평당 임대를 보면 진짜 말도
안 되게 비싸거든요. 근데 그거와
비교해서 우리나라는 진짜 너무
쌉니다. 환율도 되게 높은 상태인데
그 명품 업체 기준으로 봤을 때
우리나라 임대료가 그렇게 비싼게
아니거든요. 또 여러분들이 하나
아셔야 될게 그런 명품 업체들이 해외
부동산에 투자를 잘하진 않아요. 근데
여기 보면은 뭐 프라다도 매입하고
굿찌도 매입하고 노이비통도 매입하고
뭐 샤넬도 매입하고 이런 업체들이
매입한게 여기밖에 없어요.
대한민국에. 근데 그런 업체들이 아무
생각 없이 매입하진 않았겠죠. 심지어
프라다 같은 경우에는 90년도 중반
정도에 매입을 했어요. 아주 오래
전부터 이런 기업들이 많이 매입을 한
거리입니다. 그래서 여러분들이 한번
직접 오셔 가지고 좀 진짜 제가 왜
이렇게 흥분해서 얘기하는지 한번 좀
직접 보시면 좋을 것 같습니다.
그래서 오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요.
빌딩은 역시 빌사나
[음악]